so getting started on youtube and
figuring out what niche you should
actually be in can be a journey and
today i'm excited to bring on ben kaiser
one of our success students in our video
ranking academy where we're walking
through the steps he took to figure out
his niche how he made a pivot during his
content creation process and how he's
able to now go full time work from home
be with his family all because of the
power of youtube my name is heather
torres and you're watching the youtube
made simple show
welcome to the youtube made simple show
where we are helping you overcome fear
build confidence and launch and grow a
successful youtube channel now today i'm
excited because ben kaiser one of our
video ranking academy success students
will be joining me on the show i
interviewed ben and we talked all about
how to actually figure out your niche we
went pretty deep on this one so i want
you to stay locked and loaded and enjoy
this episode
[Music]
well i'm excited because i have been
here with me and ben is actually one of
our success students inside of video
ranking academy and in this entire
series i want to be bringing youtubers
business owners entrepreneurs to the
youtube made simple show so that we can
pick their brains and really see how
they did what they did and dive deeper
into things like today's topic on how do
you actually pick your niche so ben tell
us a little bit about who you are and
what your channel's about yeah so i am a
tech
youtuber but my
deep niche is
laptops for creative professionals so i
kind of
say like the triple niche the triple
threat so you have tech laptops and then
you have laptops for creative
professionals and so as i get deeper in
my niche i get more specific and bring
more value to a specific group of people
and when i first got started i was
nowhere near where i am now it was a lot
of searching and and testing
and just really trying to figure out how
to
find what i was going to talk about on
youtube i have a graphic design
background so i have a bachelor's and
master's degree in graphic design which
gave me my expertise in tech for
creative professionals so when people
are you know often coming to me and
saying hey what should my niche be i'll
say okay what do you like
and what is it about you that allows you
to go deeper with a specific group of
people so i also know how to sew but
what would my niche be in sewing i'm not
just going to go and sew anything that
would that wouldn't capture a specific
group of people
but i have made dresses i have made
backpacks i have made all these
different things over the years
and um that would be how i would start
to kind of think through niching down
more than just top level tech
and then working my way down to where i
am today
so awesome and i i want to break this
down a little bit more because you know
i really wanted to bring this idea of
how do you pick your niche because
you're in a big niche you're in the tech
space and when i think about tech i mean
even think media we are in the tech
space but you and i actually think media
and what you're doing isn't actually
competing because you're in your own uh
sphere inside of the tech space walk me
through how did you even decide to go
that direction what was the like
sparking point to be like i want to
record or i want to do videos around
laptops but not just laptops but for
graphic designers creative entrepreneurs
what did that look like for you yeah
okay so i'm gonna get super real with
you so
when i first got into youtube i was
working a graphic design job for a
non-profit christian missionary
organization i was making like 21 000
after taxes and my wife was a full-time
nurse so like my wife's income was was
good like that's kind of like what we
were living off of and then my income
was like hey let's buy food like that
was like all my income really did um and
so
my wife came to me about a year into
that job and she's like hey i i want to
i think we should start having children
i would love to start having children
like yeah that sounds awesome she's like
i'm going to quit my job when when we
have children and so i'm sitting there
on like 21 000 a year and i'm like oh
yeah
that's not gonna work
and so a friend of mine who worked for
the agency as well comes into my office
and i'm like hey my wife just told me
she'll quit her job and we have kids and
you know i don't make enough here and
he's like well have you ever heard of
affiliate marketing i was like no i have
no idea what that means he's like well
here here's a course i found and and
just just check this out and it was like
a really really elementary level course
about just like affiliate marketing
through like
niche websites so that's where i got
like tuned in to things
and so i started watching that course
and then i started watching youtube and
that's where i stumbled across sean's
course video ranking academy
and i
found that my goal was going to be to
sell
like other online courses for like data
analytics
and software engineering and i was going
to talk about these
niche topics and those niche topics were
going to direct
to affiliate marketing for courses and
people are going to buy courses and i
was going to make a million dollars
right like that was my that's going to
happen that was my goal
and
what i found was those videos did well i
ended up ranking like number one for
like a bunch of data analytics terms and
i literally barely knew about data
analytics i just would like research the
topic and i tried to explain it like
super simply for like the average person
who like might want to do a career
switch okay
trust me long story is going to make
sense so from there i was realizing that
okay these videos are getting a lot of
views but i wasn't selling any courses i
might sell one every other month and
make like 30 bucks and i was like this
is not working
and i was ignoring the fact that i was a
graphic designer i used a computer every
day i knew a lot about computers and how
the programs interacted with the
software inside of them and so i was
like okay you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
go ahead and make a top five best
laptops for graphic designers
i've been watching some of sean's videos
i'd yet to dive into video ranking
academy so my videos were just kind of
ranking okay at the time
but i saw i watched one of sean's videos
and he's like hey make a best of like if
you're going to start
trying to get affiliate sales i was like
i'm going to go for that so i made a top
5 best laptops video and that video just
blew up
and i was really excited i started
making some amazon affiliate commission
and i was like oh this is really cool
but i still wasn't fully committed
to that that that train and the reason
being was i didn't have a lot of laptops
i just i had a i went on amazon found a
couple laptops that looked like the one
that i was using and it worked well for
me and i kind of built this best of list
but i didn't quite have a proof of
concept
so
my wife and i went to an affiliate
marketing summit and from there we just
learned more about affiliate marketing
but it really didn't help and so it was
that point that i signed up for video
ranking academy and sean broke down like
a full system
on how to rank your videos
and also create like really a suite of
videos to dominate your niche and that's
where the green light turned on for me
and i realized these one-off videos
weren't going to
make me the money i needed to quit my
job what i realized is i needed a suite
of videos to dominate the topic and be
an owner
in my specific niche which is at the
point where i started reviewing the
laptop i had i started borrowing laptops
and then
i reached out to a few brands but we can
jump into that more so good you said a
couple things that were really
interesting ben that i want to kind of
just touch on yes one
when you jumped into youtube you did
what almost like a quote-unquote classic
mistake that people do is they're like
let me go in this totally different
direction
i'm not really very skilled in but i
know there's money in it yeah and
but every day you were using and you had
this knowledge in graphic design you had
this knowledge of how to use these
things all of those pieces and so one
takeaway if you're if you're listening
right now is if you are on the fence of
trying to figure out what your niche is
ben just gave it to you right there what
are you already doing what are the what
are the things and the tools and the
life experience you have that you're
already using
so that you can start teaching on it
that was the first thing you brought up
then the second thing that you said was
the suite of videos to dominate your
niche and
in in in this interview specifically i
really wanted to talk about how you got
into this laptop niche area and you and
what you so eloquently said like i just
looked up the best laptops i mean it
wasn't like this massive revelation of
how to get to a certain point but it's
the idea that if you want to dominate in
a niche you have to create a suite of
videos you have to create a lot of
videos because the more hooks are that
are in the ocean the more opportunities
you have for people to buy the product
so yes i know the question people are
asking right now especially in the tech
niche and then we'll get deeper into um
some of the other questions how are you
getting laptops ben how are you doing
yeah so uh that's been a long process
this year's probably and i'm about two
years in has been the year i've gotten
the most and it takes time and usually
what i tell people is
like review what you have around your
house ask your friends like i borrowed
laptops from my dad like he would buy a
new macbook pro for his job and i'd be
like hey can i borrow that for a week
and just review it
i had a few laptops just you know from
over the years being a graphic designer
but then really what i found was is like
go to third party
wholesalers or suppliers first because
they're the ones that aren't getting
like all the amazon and best buy and
direct to consumer attention they're the
ones that are trying to get sales
because normally people go straight to
let's say lenovo or hp or dell or apple
but these third-party resellers are
trying to get their their hook they're
trying to get their profit and so what i
did is i went after one of those
third-party resellers first
and i got about seven to eight laptops
from them over the course of about a
year and a half and that is what allowed
me to be able to go to other brands and
say hey i've worked with your laptop i
actually got it from this third party do
you ever work with influencers directly
that was my first step
so awesome and i want to point something
out so you're doing this
on the side with a regular job starting
a family all of those things and so i
just want to challenge listeners then
that this all you said it takes time
that's number one and it's one step at a
time once you've got that in with that
one company then you could use that
leverage for the next company and the
next time where'd you learn those skills
um
struggle that's where i learned those
skills desperation that's how i learned
those skills um i i woke up every day
for the first year of youtube at 4 30
and i would work from 4 30 to about
seven before i eat breakfast and go to
my day job um and so i me and my wife
got into i wouldn't say fights but a lot
of aggressive negotiations
on um the fact that i was working too
much so when when i was dating my wife
we hung out a ton you know we were
college students we went for bike rides
and all this stuff
i got hired full time but i was only
four days a week and she's a nurse so
she's three days a week so we hung out a
lot on fridays and saturdays well i
start youtube and i first of all i'm
waking up at 4 30 so i'm not not you
know waking up next to her when she
wakes up and i stopped taking off
fridays so i do fridays as my full
youtube day and the reason i'm saying
that is you got to really talk with your
spouse or your your girlfriend or your
boyfriend or whatever it might be that
you're like hey i'm going to get serious
about this for for a year or so because
that's where you can have some really
really big struggles in your
relationships in your life is if your
your
people you're doing life with aren't
prepared for what you're you're about to
dive into i hope we didn't sidetrack too
much there heather no that was really
good advice and and so good even to the
idea of like how do you learn all this
you just put in the work you put in the
hours but you're so right i mean even
when it comes to just doing doing
youtube doing anything new that's gonna
take away time from
your life especially trying to grow a
youtube channel it is going to take time
it is going to take dedication
perseverance it's going to take the um
my friend ben azadi says the suck sucks
suck before you get to success
it takes a while
to get there yeah um so
i would like to know though when you
were making those first couple videos
and then you and then you really looked
at the analytics and you're like no i'm
going to pivot into laptops i'm going to
pivot into helping creative
entrepreneurs which by the way is a huge
niche even though it sounds like a small
niche like i helped create it is it is a
mult it's probably a billion dollar
niche when it comes to laptops
accessories software i mean the the
ability to tap into that
it feels restrictive though right like
it really rather than tech it's
restrictive so
walk me through some of the fears when
you're like no i am going to make this
pivot and you kind of like planted your
flag in the ground to say no i'm going
to help this group of people with this
one problem
walk me through like how you mentally
prepared yourself for for the feeling of
the restrictiveness that comes with it
yeah and you know i'd like to say i had
fears on the restrictiveness
but really it was more the fear of like
uh i don't even know how to say this
because it was restricted but it was
more of the fear of i'm not gonna make
money quick enough
which i think is more of a fear of
restrictiveness but it didn't feel like
that at the moment if that makes sense
go deeper why why
because you know when you see like a
large pool you're like oh i can capture
like all these views you know i see
dave2d i see
marquez brownlee i see
jared's tech and these guys are like
doing these gaming niches with billions
and billions of gamers where i'm talking
like
hundreds of millions of creators and so
for me it was like i'm gonna miss all
those people like i didn't do gaming
benchmarks i didn't do
all of that
niche which really people would
basically yelled at me in the comment
section for a good year that i was not
doing gaming benchmarks but i knew if i
could bring the most value to this one
group of people that it would ultimately
pay off
but that was hard because
i just saw that i would miss out on like
you're saying this whole group of people
but what i came to find out through sean
is would you rather
own 10 percent
of the world
or have like point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero one percent
of
like the entire world so would you
rather own one world
or have a tiny tiny tiny portion of the
entire world and i was like well it
makes more sense to own one world
anytime somebody searches
video editing or graphic design in
correlation to laptops you see this face
and so
that just ended up making more sense
yeah now let's go you don't have to go
into like actual full-on numbers but
when you made that pivot and you decided
no i'm gonna do this because ultimately
you do want this to be a career you want
to be able to be at home with your
family to be able to you know uh create
the freedom in your lifestyle and and
not have the the um you know day-to-day
you know nine-to-five job
what did this do income wise when that
actually was the fear
yeah so i was doing pretty good
uh making you know these kind of best of
videos and and line up videos but then
when i fully pivoted and started getting
laptops and started reviewing them
um it was about fourteen thousand
dollars for the year in
2019
and i was really starting to commit but
then i went to ces
in 2020 and met face to face with brands
and said hey this is my plan i'm going
to start i'm going all in on creative
professionals
and at that point i was able to get
face-to-face with brands and start
getting some more computers and when i
made that pivot
that year i ended up hitting
pre-tax i want to say it was like
75 000
roughly no sorry sorry
35 000.
so i ended up going 35 000 so it was
almost a 4x return going all in
um and that that so that really made the
biggest difference
yeah and it and it's going to be the
catalyst into the next season the next
season of going full time the next
season of creating more content the next
season of building a team all because
you chose a niche ben right yeah exactly
exactly i got serious about one group of
people and i decided that i was going to
show up anytime somebody hit search in
relation to what i was doing
now a lot of times too when you make
that pivot and you go no i'm going all
in on that
did you um this is a
this is a question that i'm like i know
the answer but i want to i want the
audience to hear it yeah did actually
when you said i'm going all in on this
group of people did all of a sudden
there became like 25 other opportunities
in that niche because you're like no i'm
going to zone in on these people and
then all and then all of a sudden you
see all these other problems that you
can solve for those exact people yeah
and i think the way that that transpires
is when you first enter a niche for
instance for me
tech
you see like all these questions already
answered so some questions that stand
out to me are like
what is a cpu what is a gpu what is ram
what is storage and all those questions
are answered so when i first came in i'm
like all these questions are answered
i've got nothing i can do about that but
then when you niche down what you can do
is
what does a gpu mean for graphic design
what is the best cpu for video editing
cpu is explained for video editors and
then i could go on and on i have like 50
videos about topics that people have
already filmed
that i didn't really know super
well but what i did is i took my
knowledge of video editing and graphic
design i watched
linus tech tips video on cpu so i
understood them better and then i
explained
how what the implications were for video
editing and graphic design because he
was talking to generalists and gamers
which made no sense to the creative
professional industry
yeah man so many nuggets there the idea
that i'm i'm like i'm gonna take notes
because i want to do that too i'm like
what is someone sharing here's a power
tip what is someone sharing in a
generalized way yes that you can then
take that information and share it in
your specific way that's a challenge to
you who are watching the show right now
exactly figure that out figure out how
you can then make something that's
generalized very specific because people
type in
for what they're doing i i do make
videos like this for my home school
channel like how to start homeschooling
only a homeschool mom or dad is gonna
search that right it's calling out the
person so by you doing that and saying
for video editors actually allows for it
to be specific to their actual problem
all right then i would like to know what
is your advice for someone who's just
starting out obviously they're watching
this video how to find your niche how to
pick a niche what advice do you have if
they are ben two years ago
i i mean i would say first of all like
at a base level just commit to a year
and more than that like commit to a
spree because what that does is that
allows you to get as much data as
possible into your channel in a short
amount of time so when i started i said
i was going to record six days a week
for 60 days and so what that did is it
allowed me to just drive a ton of
content into my channel so that at the
end of 60 days i could see what worked
and what didn't
now keep in mind that that was data
analytics so
my the first step if i could go back was
to focus on something that i was good at
and i knew about and was already in my
brain as a tool set of skills that i had
so but then after you decide on that
niche and something that you're good at
and you have knowledge on do that spree
because then what you can do is look
back and see what worked
and then replicate that and do more of
that
that's that's really the kickoff point
of how i would start so one of the
things i see a lot ben is uh is that
when before someone starts they actually
wait so i want to know how long did you
wait to get started they'll be thinking
about it iterating about it what videos
that should they do were you someone who
waited and if you if not why do you
think that
that's a fantastic question because that
is what i see
the biggest differentiator between
people who start on youtube and win and
people who
continue to wait and i think for me
my biggest benefit of my personality is
i'm not afraid to fail
um and i did not wait at all as soon as
i figured out that you could post videos
on youtube that did not have to be funny
cat videos or old super bowl commercials
i was like
and it's free i was like why are we not
doing this that ben um and so i think
what i
did was i was relentless
and fearless
in the fact that i was not afraid to be
wrong
my first videos i'm embarrassed how
often i wasn't not 100 wrong but i
definitely wasn't right
and the laptops that i recommended
worked for graphic design but they
weren't really the best for graphic
design
but i realized looking back that
people still got value from that video
and people still were appreciative of
the explanation
and the recommendations that were made
now i talked to a lot of people about
starting youtube channels my wife says i
should stop because basically everybody
i talk to i'm like you need to start a
youtube channel and she says ben
not everybody wants to start a youtube
channel i'm like no but everybody has to
and the biggest fear that i i
listen to when i'm talking to people
about starting youtube channel is
they're so afraid that they might say
something wrong
um they say
what if what if i don't what if i'm
incorrect i'm like bro this ain't a
textbook
like there's no right and wrong here
like
you have interpretation i have a friend
who's an insane reader i mean he can
read 30 books in like
15 days if you wanted to and i'm like
bro like why don't you do book reviews
or like philosophy unboxings or
unpackings i don't know what you'd call
him as a philosopher but and he's like
yeah but like what if i'm wrong
and i'm like
who cares like you're gonna be wrong and
i think like that's probably the biggest
uh fire that i have burning in me is i'm
not afraid to be wrong i have people
commented today how wrong one of my
videos was that i posted 15 minutes ago
and you know what
they're right
it was wrong
i didn't get it right but guess what
i'll learn
and i'll make it better next time and i
think that's the biggest thing is don't
be afraid
to be wrong because you know what
somebody's gonna comment
somebody's gonna tell you that you're
wrong you get to research and the next
time you get to do it right
i just
ugh
don't be afraid of that
so good so good and yeah it's also uh
you said a little bit ago even like the
analysis paralysis what video should i
do how long should the video be should i
do this background should it be that
background and i'm like just pick up the
camera and make the video because it's
probably not going to be your best video
i think that's the fear
well what if this goes viral it's
probably not going to one of my best
video best this this videos in german
coming out one of my best videos is
completely out of focus
like
best laptops for photoshop 150 000 views
in like six months completely out of
focus but i was like i'm not going to
reshoot it i've got to go to work so i
posted it and it took off and
everybody's like this is out of focus
but it was really helpful
so funny
yeah
we uh we had that with the podcast when
we first started this video podcast at
first we were just gonna do audio only
and then we're like we're the video
people we should probably set up a
camera and actually start a video
podcast and sean and i had written our
notes because we were gonna i was gonna
read the intro that we had written 10
minutes ago of the podcast so in the
first like six episodes i'm reading the
intro like welcome to the think it was
called think marketing then so we even
changed the name yeah
i was welcome to the think marketing
podcast and i'm reading it and literally
just just eating alive in the comments
of like why is she reading you should
not read look at the thing i'm thinking
you're so beautiful these podcasts have
thousands of views on them me reading
doesn't matter
i also think another fear in getting
started is i'm afraid that this is what
i'm going to do for the rest of my life
oh yeah so one thing that my my dad so
my dad he's an incredible project
manager he actually does big signage in
vegas like all the big led signs and
like all the the strip and all that
that's like stuff that he does and he's
an incredible product manager and i'm
like dad like why don't you like do
courses on project management like you
can make you make bank consulting to
other companies for project management
my dad has this idea that he wants to be
like in real estate and i'm like okay
cool but why don't you like make a ton
of money
and then pour it into real estate
and then you can do both and this is the
thing with like tech reviews people are
like oh do you love laptops i'm like
yeah laptops are cool but i'm not in
love with them because i have like a
larger vision of life
but laptops and and learning youtube is
on the path towards where i'm going and
so don't be afraid that if you start one
thing
that you're gonna be on it forever like
you have to get monetized like sean says
you got to get money for the mission and
me and my wife have a secret project
that we're working on that you could
find it on youtube if you you know could
figure it out but it's something that
makes no money but because i have the
tech channel which has incredible
affiliate marketing sales we can do that
channel and build that opportunity and
one day maybe that secret project will
make money
so good yeah it's and and and really i
mean i think about this too i'm the
youtube girl i'm like yeah but i'm also
so many other things but you know
it opens up the door
to more opportunity so when you're
thinking about starting you're thinking
about picking your niche
just pick one and just go head first
into it because that's going to be i say
you you won't even know the
possibilities on the other side of just
saying yes like you're going to learn
so much you're going to learn so much
more than you ever realize like who i am
today versus who i was when i got
married my wife and i look at each other
and we're like we are nobody who we when
we got married but we're like
thank the lord like we are so happy who
we were we got married but we're even
happier with who we are now on this
journey it's just it's incredible great
advice and you're on your way to 100 000
subscribers
on your way to full time that's coming
very soon and i just want to applaud you
and say thank you for being one of our
success students that we could highlight
it's always awesome to be able to bring
on um students who are doing the work
that are actually putting in the hours
actually following the system and really
making impact not just in their world
but in other people's lives so ben where
can they go if they want to follow along
on your journey if they're a creative
entrepreneur and want to know what type
of laptop they should use or if they
just want to like peek into your world
and see the types of videos you're
creating yeah so on youtube i'm just ben
g kaiser and so youtube.com benji kaiser
it is the only platform i'm on and that
would be another
power tip
don't dabble in everything go deep on
one thing and then when you hire a team
like shawn and heather have done then
you can do everything
don't do it once
our tips i love it well thanks for being
on the show today
thanks for having me
well i hope you enjoyed that interview
with ben and i would love to know down
in the comments section what other
niches would you like me to feature on
the show we have so many success
students inside of video ranking academy
that all i need to do is send them a dm
and they will show up on the show so let
me know in the comments what niches do
you want to hear from on this show now
like i mentioned ben is a part of our
video ranking academy this is a
different program but if you're
interested in learning more about our
advanced courses you can go to
startvra.com if you want to learn how to
join video ranking academy thank you so
much for being a part of this youtube
made simple community i love being able
to show all of the success students that
we have and bring on other guests to
talk about how do we just keep it simple
how do we make youtube happen and how
can we do this and fit it into our
lifestyles right now thanks for being a
part of the show and we'll catch you in
the next episode
[Music]
you